two things changed in the market first
is the market
and second is the perception of
compliance why the market change
due to the amount of cloud adoption the
more
cloud infrastructure in sas products
companies use
the easier it is and intuitive it is to
automatically
get data normalize it trust it
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance opposed labs touring
hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders
so developers have jira sales reps have
sales force
now infosec leaders have anecdotes meet
yael kuznetsov co-founder and ceo of
anecdotes
after building and managing teams in
different places in the idf intelligence
corps
he was head of the hardcore r d section
of 8200
he then took a giant risk and built a
new sas product for insight
hoping it quickly adapted to the modern
tech stack and it turned out to be very
successful
he started anecdotes with two friends
roy and ayton and they currently have 30
employees in tel aviv
transforming from r d manager to ceo
means managing marketing and sales which
is another big move for him
but it seems like it's working out so
far because modern r d teams and modern
marketing and sales departments
actually turn out to be pretty similar
meet yeah
yeah welcome to 20 minute leaders how
are you today
i'm good i'm good how are you thanks i'm
good we're going to talk about
an up-and-coming industry that i think
wasn't hugely relevant even five or ten
years ago but today is
is exploding i personally experienced it
firsthand where i work
and and and i think that what we're
seeing in both the israel ecosystem but
the world
you know there's a huge thirst for this
and it's a huge pain points uh you're
the co-founder and ceo of anecdotes from
over the past two years i believe
previously had insights previously
before that in one of the most
incredible places in the idf in one of
the most
uh thought thoughtful and rigorous
challenging places
uh that that unfortunately we can't talk
too much about but we can talk about how
you're bringing the
same intellectual curiosity and rigor to
what you're doing today so
even before we dive deep into anecdotes
sale tell me a little bit about about
yourself
how you get into you know computer
science
and eventually what leads you to think
through compliance and infosec
all right those are great questions um
so i'm 30 years old i was a computer
geek
but not the classic ones went to
university
studied computer science and economics
once in that thing
led to the other and then i happened to
myself very interested in
network security back in the days
uh 12 years ago network security was
completely different
it's not what it is today but it was a
great way to get to the army in a very
specific area
i find myself enjoying what i'm doing
researching networks
researching technology building
technology i was building teams
then was head of r d section
and as a an army carrier that was really
interesting very intense
but the world outside is amazing and the
amount of technology here
is infinite and i was willing to make
the jump go outside
and see how we can fit in leveraging the
knowledge the
technology the state of mind and this
modern ecosystem of
um that's why i joined insight before
and before we
before we continue just mention this
idea of a state of mind bringing the
state of mind
in in a few sentences how do you
interpret
the state of mind from your time in
where you were in the army
we don't know anything or everything but
we have one thing we can always trust
and it's the ability
to take a challenge and just make sure
that we do the best we can
to overcome it this is like a
fundamental
state of mind that we always encourage
every young soldier
every professional i had doctors working
in my
department and this state of mind is a
huge advantage and it's just a state of
mind so
taking this ability to an industry
in different industry such as influencer
compliance
is absolutely the fundamentals of
building this
great company that we have amazing so so
a few words about
insights and and what do you learn from
there and then
walk me through the conviction that you
got in the compliance and infosec world
yeah so insight was a whole different uh
company different domain
uh i had a great opportunity to build
uh create a new business unit there and
build a new product
sas pure sales product and that was a
really great
opportunity for me to experiment we're
building a
solution in a red ocean market and
taking this to the market
we saw great success in the first year
and i was like
all right wait i can replicate
what i know outside through modern
technology through modern
markets let's do something that i truly
believe is positive
and i grew up in the cyber security it
is true
i love cyber security it's fascinating
the amount of technology there is crazy
but outside fun is one of the most
commonly used uh practices for selling
stuff
and i was willing to play in this
fear uh and doubt and answer doubt and
uncertainty
and i was like all right let's do
something positive
let's not tell people that they might be
attacked
so one thing led to the other and i was
sitting with two friends
and we're like all cyber security people
trying to figure out what can we do that
is positive
and so and then and then compliance
positivity
right so so compliance as a word
it doesn't automatically translate to me
as positive impact
or or something that makes others happy
right what is compliance in the
high-tech world and then
and then what do you do there
exactly so compliance is not positive at
its
basics the whole idea is that compliance
is something that's here
and infosec compliance those frameworks
that we all know suck to
whatever eyes of pci hipaa
those kind of frameworks are actually
great frameworks
smart people were thinking of how to
build them in a way that will help
companies improve their security and
their
uh performance and the idea is that due
to
lack of technology it's lack of
technology it's manual
it's manual it's labor intensive and no
one is willing to handle
and deal with infrastructure compliance
so
the reason why we realized
infrastructure compliance is positive
and can
serve to positive targets is if we can
leverage modern technology
and just bring the ability to automate
huge amount
of the tedious process that's now done
manually we can then focus or allow our
customers
to focus on what matters which is make
sure
that the procedures you have are great
don't waste any
anyone's time so
why is it positive because it can help
you eventually
but we start by
understanding that it's here to stay
right interested compliance those
certifications are not changing
mm-hmm now we're willing to
walk me back a little bit and you know
take me 30 000 feet in the air
you know as you know company leaders why
would anyone
want to do compliance why is this how
does compliance
play a part in the ecosystem is it
mandatory is it optional is it for
you know how does the ecosystem work
with compliance and infosec today
right so most of the compliance
certifications are not mandatory
but the idea is that the ecosystem
requires companies to have those kind of
certifications
so back in the days five years ago 10
years ago
if i was a unicorn or a hyper growth
company i needed to have sock too
because my big customers the financial
industry required talk to
sometimes id27 but this is it nowadays
what happened
is that data is moving all around the
world
with different vendors holding and
having different parts
crucial parts for the company for the
corporate a company
so compliance certifications became
a commodity if you don't have this at
the very beginning
this is it you can't play
no that makes a lot of sense and that's
why is the challenge
with that so the i understand the manual
aspect of it
and you know when you come in and you
say using technology we can we can
we can augment it is it mainly based on
speed on timeliness and the ability to
do it
so let's describe for a second the
ecosystem of infosec compliance
there's the company there are the
auditors and their consultants
now what happens is that there is a big
mess inside a company
because they need to make sure that they
comply or they
follow some guidelines from a specific
framework
but they need consultants to tell them
what to do and how to do it
and they need the auditors to approve it
to audit
what they have and each one of them
speaks a different language this is the
biggest gap here
because consultants has one terminology
auditors have different things
and we like modern companies we're like
cloud native companies cloud oriented
companies
we don't care about old things we want
it to be
efficient we want it to be automatic we
want to rely on data
and this is a big promise of anecdotes
we're the first to bring this concept of
take data real data
as an evidence as the fundamentals for
infrastructure compliance
and simply rely on data as simple as
that
but this is a very big change in the
ecosystem of infrastructure compliance
right now as you as you're building the
startup and you're starting out
you have you know basically going to
companies that need to do complaints
which means they're already a little bit
further along their life cycle probably
than you are in your and you're
trying to integrate and handle their
data and and
start to replace manual work what are
some of the challenges
as the entrepreneur now that that you're
facing
as you're even trying to get the the
first people on board and trying to
really understand
how do you actually begin working with
with these companies
so there are two challenges uh the first
challenge is the obvious one
as a vendor i need to be trusted
and here's the egg and the chicken so we
go through certification processes
but we also maintain very high level of
security standards in the company
because we can't sell to modern
enterprises unicorns hyper growth
companies and even startups
a solution such as anecdotes and tell
them all right trust us we're fine
the world has changed dramatically so we
had to
simply implement this concept of
security by design
to our entire life cycle of building the
platform
from day one security was here so
we chose to invest a lot of time and
money on this to make sure
that whenever we approach a unicorn
they can fully trust anecdotes based on
the security measurements that we have
that's the first first challenge the
second one
is knowledge so we're secure cyber
security guys here
we were sitting mostly in tel aviv 30
employees we grew up pretty fast
but we needed someone or a team
that comes with a very deep knowledge
and understanding of compliance
of how practically infrastruct
compliance
can be fulfilled using data and that was
a really
important piece of uh this puzzle that
we put together
at the very beginning we built a team of
compliance experts
that's what they did for living for
decades
and together with our product team we
now have the ability
to speak the terminology of the auditors
but also have a very modern intuitive
approach for customers
was there as you're thinking through
anecdotes and you're you're planning
ahead and you're thinking about the
product market fit and you're testing
some some
hypotheses was there was there a single
aha moment
where or or any specific time when you
said like wow like now i believe this
like this is
like a switch went on or was it more
gradual research that over time you
became more and more convinced
it was a very nice aha moment i was when
i went through stock to myself when i
worked at insights
and the product that we developed and
i was taking screenshots i don't know i
was
taking screenshots from different
platforms in my group
and sending it to the auditor and a year
later
i was sitting through the lockdown
during covid
with my friends trying to figure out
what we really want to do
and then we were like all right but how
come people take screenshots
let's go figure out if someone was
saving dollars on
me or if this really how it happens
so we had meetings with dozens of
different companies in the states
different factors
different size and apparently everyone
taking screenshots
everyone using labor
to uh to manually collect this thing and
hopefully analyze it afterwards when we
saw
50 companies banks insurance companies
medium size startups or modern
unicorns they're all doing the same we
were like all right
we can change this we have to change
this
that was the very smooth moment
wow and so so walk me through a little
bit of the vision that you have for this
so you're you're
you're relatively in the beginning of
the journey 30 employees in tel aviv it
sounds like you from what we discussed
before you have some
some incredible incredible companies
already trusting you and leveraging your
solutions but
but take it play a game with me a few
years down the line
where do you see the compliance and
infosec industry go
in terms of the integration of
technology with with this
what it sounds like very manual
intensive labor
so i think um in a few years from now
not 10 years but we can discuss three
years three to five years
what we're trying to do and what we're
going to hopefully achieve
is people will look at compliance
certifications
not as a burden but as something that
they do want to adopt
as early as possible and once again not
because
the market demands it but because these
are the great guidelines
of how to progress and improve your
security
now we're not going to replace
any cspm or idp solution
that's not us we're just trying to be
this commodity solution very nice
and beautiful product that helps you
understand all right
i'm big enough to bring an idp or
right now i need a network security
scanner
so that you can see what are the
guidelines what's the benchmark
in the industry right this is the very
big vision
and that's why we can truly believe we
can shift compliance
to be based on data and therefore
accurate
and therefore positive now timing
obviously is always a huge huge factor
so this says that you know compliance
sucked to it it's been around for for
dozens of years
uh and uh you know at least 20 30 years
you know with
with a high tech and why now so why now
why not you know why isn't
isn't there a you know global solution
already from five years ago
and why not wait two or three years
until there's
more more you know that it becomes more
and more trivial so
what's happening why is it not the right
time to do this
so two things changed in the market
first is the market and second is the
perception of compliance
why the market changed due to the amount
of cloud adoption
the more cloud infrastructure and sas
products
companies use the easier it is and
intuitive it is
to automatically get data normalize it
trust it right but this is a very big
change that happened in the past few
years
10 years ago it was impossible
right the other part is that
awareness became wide
and nowadays i'm selling to companies
i'm selling to
big enterprises medium medium companies
and startups
guess what they're all asking me about
security
back in the days it used to be all right
if i'm bank of america
i'll go through a security questionnaire
and some deep dive
uh security oriented with a vendor
nowadays
it's everyone right and i think this is
great
because people want to make sure that
when they bring a vendor
they trust it they trust the vendor
right
and those two things combined in a very
nice synergy
in the past year and it's very new
so those two things together created a
big opportunity for us that's that
that's very very cool and i
and and i love the the greater
perspective of where where this is
headed and
and i think that that you're absolutely
right that you know we're living in a
time where
it's becoming more and more common and
even if you're a small
you know it's just an early stage
startup and you want to start selling to
some of these vendors they require these
complaints now it's becoming more of a
commodity
and and as it becomes a commodity then
it just makes sense to be able to
democratize it and be able to to
leverage to leverage
good technology to actually do it
properly and at the end
compliance is just to make sure that
things are working properly
the data flows properly that you're
actually adhering to to policies that
are there to protect
the end users to protect the integrity
of the business and so
from the get go your your success
anecdotes
translates to companies adhering to
regulations that are there to enforce
good behavior
and and that is the positive impact that
we're talking about right
exactly this is exactly it amazing and
that's why
we're not selling the fastest way to
achieve sock do
this is not what we're trying to do here
we want companies to rely on this
platform to guide them
through their journey of scaling their
compliance
and this is the interesting part very
very cool
yeah it's amazing thank you so much for
sharing with me your story of anecdotes
and your own convictions and i think
it's
it's just fascinating i do have three
questions about your ill not about
anecdotes or infosector compliance
and we'll start off with middle school
and high school what was your favorite
subject
growing up what fascinated you as a kid
music actually i was playing yeah
for a decade piano on guitar i loved it
and i was in a crossroads music
or technology amazing
if you look at your path somebody that
inspired you
and you know any type of role model or
some sort of inspiration
i had a teacher one teacher one special
one he wasn't really a teacher but he
was in school
and he told me listening here it was 15
years ago
computer science and programming is
great
but that's not the end game look beyond
programming programming is going to be
the cards
in couple years from now but look
forward what do you want to achieve
with programming don't just be a
programmer
that was inspiring i love it and what
are three words that you would use to
describe yourself
ambitious um fascinated by
plenty of things and curious
i love it best of luck with anecdotes
this is wonderful
and and i look forward to continue
seeing more and more companies use it
and i look forward to using it myself
and my own startup one day
so thank you very much thanks being here
it's a pleasure meeting you this morning
bye bye
[Music]
you